all right hi my name is Tomo it's after
lunch it's like the low-energy time of
the day I'm very flattered and gratified
that you all chose to be here instead of
any of the other glorious sessions that
we have in this slot - room is packed so
I hope that you manage to be comfortable
because for the next 40 minutes or so
we're gonna be talking about micro
services now micro services is not
exactly a new subject it's been
discussed in hundreds maybe even
thousands of blog post conference talks
you know people have been writing books
about it and discussing it in every
which way for upwards of a decade so
this is very far from being a new
subject and just having this many people
in the room tells me that this would be
a good opportunity to stop take a deep
breath take a step back and look at
micro services as a topic with a first
perspective from the point of view of a
decade of industry experience building
and running systems in that particular
architecture so our menu for today
includes a short recap on why we even do
micro services what it is we hope to get
out of them what we as an industry have
managed to learn you know following that
decade of building these systems what we
as an industry
I feel have failed to learn that I think
might very well be more important and my
own personal opinion or take on what it
is we should or should not be doing in
order to continue realizing the benefits
of this architecture moving forward
despite my usual inclination of not
introducing myself in this case I think
a short introduction is in order so Who
am I my name is Donnell Gobbo I come
from Israel an occasional public speaker
I'm a software engineer at we work prior
to we work I had spent five years at a
company you may have heard of called Wix
that is very much a proponent and early
adopter of micro service architectures
before that a bunch of other companies
most of which ended up with a Microsoft
microservice like architecture I like to
style myself a technology malcontent
means I have very strong opinions that
oftentimes go sort of against the grain
of accepted or common wisdom in the
industry with respect to various things
specifically that right there is me
railing against dependency injection but
in this case I'm not actually gonna
inflict a forty minute long rant on you
but instead I'm hoping that the reason
I'm telling you all this
predominantly is not because I'm smart
or cool or any of these things it's
because I'm reasonably old and I've seen
a bunch of companies I have seen micro
service based architectures fail I've
seen them succeed I think it gives me a
a reasonable perspective to draw some
conclusions that may or may not be of
benefit to you hopefully they will so
let's get started with all recap right
microservices not a new thing but I
think it's worth revisiting why it is we
do micro services in the first place so
if we've been consuming the serv
material that's been around for the last
decade with respect to micro services
you will probably end up thinking micro
services are a thing we do for three
major reasons the first reason is
developer velocity the assumption is if
you have a business you have a large
system you have a large business and you
manage to take that business and
decompose it into smaller bits right if
you can if you can break down your
business into separate shall we say sub
businesses or sub systems domains you
can call what you will and you managed
to build a a strong wall around each one
of these domains so that they can be
dealt with independently you have gained
some value you have gained developer
velocity you have gained the ability to
independently release different parts of
your system you have limited the scope
of work for any particular group of
people be it a team and as we all know
working on fewer things is easier it
means you can move faster it means you
can reason about
those things better and it leads to
stronger decoupling which means teams
can move forward independently and a lot
quicker than they would in a traditional
monolithic architecture now it's
important to note that you can only
realize these benefits if you actually
manage to take your business to take
your system and break it down into truly
independent things truly independent
substrata that you can actually build a
strong wall around and that wall keeps
things in order keeps things moving
fluidly forward in the DDD world we like
to call this bounded context right and
bounded context is the driver bounded
context is sort of the prerequisite that
you have to realize any of the perceived
benefits of micro-services starting with
increased developer velocity the second
major reason why we do micro services is
scalability especially for early
adopters that were sort of writing and
producing talks about this subject in in
the early years of this decade the
Twitter's of the world the Netflix's of
the world one of the things that
commonly comes up is the ability to
scale your system better if you can
break down your system into these
independent parts you can start
independently scaling these parts you
can choose independent storage that is
again assuming you have made the
sensible choice of disallowing every one
of these components from accessing the
storage of any other subsystem so you
can choose the right tool for the job
you can choose different storage engines
you can scale your storage independently
you can scale your services
independently and you realize a greater
total scale for your system there's also
the fact that any system that's
reasonably small is much easier to
optimize than a big system that does a
lot of different things as any database
administrator will tell you it is much
easier to take a small database with a
small set of tables and optimize that
over one large instance that contains
many many different use cases many
different pieces of functionality for
different services
just that much easier to optimize and
again you can only realize that benefit
if you actually managed to have bounded
context if you actually managed to break
down your system and have those very
high walls between the different parts
the third canonical reason why sort of
why the industry has been moving in that
direction
is resilience the assumption is with a
system that's broken down and broken
down into many independent parts you
have much better error boundaries
between the different parts of your
system and the system becomes more
resilient or at least potentially more
resilient to partial failures the
canonical example for this would be
Netflix's recommendation engine let's
assume you're a Netflix user as I
imagine a lot of you are let's assume
you have a particular show that's your
favorite say Lucifer which by the way is
it in my opinion a terrible show but to
each his own right and when you go to
Netflix com or you start your Netflix
app on your Android TV or whatever it is
that you do typically you have a
recommendation engine that gives you a
personalized recommendation for you
right because you have watched Lucifer
you may be interested in insert your
favorite other terrible set of shows
crucially though if the accommodation
engine fails right their accommodation
engine is down for whatever reason does
that mean Netflix is down just because
Netflix can tell you that you know
because you liked Lucifer you may like
this other thing does that mean you
don't get to watch your favorite show
obviously that would be a terrible user
experience but in a traditional
monolithic app where you have everything
stuck into one single application that's
you know deployed on multiple servers
and you have one monolithic database
that serves all of your needs it becomes
so much harder to deal with issues
independently that in effect any major
issue will bring your whole system down
so a distributed system a non monolithic
application generally has the
opportunity to deal with these partial
errors
a much nicer more streamlined way now
there are also some ancillary or
secondary benefits to using micro
services
the two most outed ones are polyglot
development in other words the ability
to develop independent parts of the
system in different text acts different
languages that is obviously something
you can do in a micro service based
architecture and is obviously impossible
to do in a monolithic app the other
claim is that a micro service based
system is easier to test now I don't
have a strong opinion on this I think
it's it might be a spurious argument but
then its might there might also be a
point to it this is all sort of
ancillary to the set of things I want to
talk about so will not be delving into
that these are the claims and once again
with all these things you can only
realize these benefits if you actually
have that bounded context in place so
far so good
deed this is I hope a reasonably
complete recap of why everyone seems to
be all gung-ho about micro services and
had been for the past decade my first
quasi controversial opinion is that we
don't actually do micro services for any
of these reasons it's all about
organizational scaling micro services
are an enabler for organizational scale
allow me to explain take any software
company write any any successful
software based product company let's
assume once again it's a start-up it's
successful it wants to grow right no no
software company that I know of no
business that I know of is content with
having one successful product and then
just going into maintenance mode firing
most of the staff and just keeping that
product alive until it becomes
irrelevant and dies off a successful
organization generally wants to make
more products wants to grow it wants to
make more money in order to build more
products do you generally have to have
more developers and you have to form
teams
of these developers and those teams
become increasingly more and more
interdependence you have you have in a
successful organization you also have
issues around visibility so for instance
if you look at Twitter when they started
off and they failed no one cared right
when you have a few thousands a few tens
of thousands of users and you fail no
notices but with success with the
millions of users that twitter has if
you remember way back let's say eight
years ago Twitter would fail constantly
it got to the point where we as an
industry I hope we've started forgetting
that concept of the fail whale that you
would get when Twitter broke which
happens fairly often right you have lots
of users those users care they want to
use your system and if your system is
unavailable it's gonna matter
so that's visibility the other side of
the coin is liability so let's take
Facebook for instance when Facebook was
a small start-up that had a hundred
thousand users no one cared what sort of
experimentation they did on their
newsfeed or what algorithms they're
running or whether or not they do
sentiment analysis and try to adjust in
newsfeed no one cared because it was
small but a billion or so users later
suddenly you have congressional hearings
about the very same experiments that
they're running suddenly everyone cares
the company becomes liable so all of
that converges to your software
engineers having more and more
responsibility write more products more
interdependence more visibility more
liability means more and more
responsibility is sort of thrown into
the mix of your everyday software
engineering lives crucially as you grow
typically what happens with any software
company is you have a product and then
you either build a second product that
shares a lot of the same code and a lot
of the same infrastructure as the first
product or you have a main product and
an ecosystem of sort of ancillary
secondary products around it it is
exceedingly rare for a software company
to have two or more completely
independent
completely unrelated software software
products in at play so the products
themselves become more and more
interdependent they rely on each other
to actually get the value to the user
and so duty interesting and so do teams
right the teams themselves become more
and more interdependent they rely on the
work done by other teams within the
organization to get their work done and
that incurs a synchronization cost now
this shouldn't be news to anyone
especially given Adam Thornhill's
excellent keynote yesterday which talked
about exactly death synchronization is
the productivity killer let's delve a
little bit into that you might say so
what you have more products more teams
more software more interdependence
between the teams that doesn't
necessarily sound like a bad thing so
let's take a look at one of the very few
sort of industry academy like research
done by industry in conjunction with
Academy and this is in this book called
accelerate which tried to take a
quantitative approach to DevOps now
there's a lot of different things in
this book that I'm not going to cover
but crucially they've identified four
metrics that they have found a strong
correlation between those metrics and
what they call highly productive or
highly successful organization the
googles of the world the Netflix's of
the world those metrics include lead
time ie
how long does it take from what
unfortunately came to be called ideation
to execution deployment frequency mean
time to recovery like given a issue that
you have in production how long does it
take to recover service for that
particular issue and change fell
percentage which is how often do you
deploy things that are broken and you
will notice that each and every one of
these metrics is negatively and severely
affected by synchronization if you have
an issue in production and you need to
start synchronizing between the teams to
figure out who
owns that issue like we're in your micro
service architecture your micro service
strata that issue exists
that's a synchronization cost right and
that's just one example every single one
of these metrics is severely and
adversely affected by synchronization in
other words what we're shooting for in
order to grow our organization what we
need to do is we need to strive for
minimal synchronization between people
and between teams and maximum
independence we need our organization to
be comprised of teams that can move
independently that don't have to wait
for anyone to get their work done
lease synchronization max and
independence gets you organizational
skinny and it turns out that micro
services are sort of intrinsically a
great fit for that because a micro
service based architecture fundamentally
is about minimal synchronization and
maximum independence of teams let us
again take a deep breath and start
considering what it is that we've
learned as an industry with respect to
micro services right take 10 years back
what lessons have we as an industry
fully internalized about micro services
the first lesson is that small is good
again tying back to the keynote from
yesterday we know that humans are
terrible at maintaining large states in
our head that's what computers are for
and therefore the less you have to
keeping your head in order to get your
work done
the better also less code means less
bucks right that's obvious but really
what we want to be focusing about is
smaller interfaces what we want is for
our systems to be comprised of many many
smaller systems again that can move
independently and the smart interface is
smaller the API surface area of each and
every one of these components the easier
they are to reason about small
interfaces are good right whatever
language you work in typically if you go
into an interface definition and there's
whatever three methods in there it's
almost trivial to figure out what the
interface is about and
what it can do and it's also easier to
evolve it because there's less cruft
there's less technical debt there's less
is the Terek use cases involved you need
to keep less stuff in your head in order
to reason about and evolve those
interfaces and I will add that it's not
easy it's a lot of discipline a lot of
work to keep those interfaces small
there are trade-offs involved you may
have to forego small interfaces for
performance reasons for instance or
because you have an annoying boss that
keeps asking you for new features
yesterday it takes a lot of discipline
to keep those interfaces small but if
you manage to keep those interfaces
small you will have realized the
benefits of smaller smaller systems
you'll be able to deal with those
systems independently and this all
results in lower coupling with inner
systems and that I feel is one of the
lessons with an industry have learned
and when I say small one thing that that
drives me nuts is that we are still
occasionally having these discussions
about what makes a micro Service micro
is it 20 lines of code or two hundred or
two thousand is it a two Pizza team is
it a five person team maybe it's just
having up to three endpoints in your
service or maybe one of these
discussions are totally useless
there are proxy metrics at best they
don't give you what you want what you
want is a minimal API surface area
pardon and that by the way is also the
reason why you should never ever share
data stores between your services I
think that there had never been or I
haven't yet run into a solid explanation
of why that's a good practice even
though intuitively everyone sort of
agrees on that it is because if you
share your database you have expanded
your API to include sequel and sequel is
not a small API right so you want to
keep your API small so that the system
can evolve independently of other
systems so that you retain lower
coupling next polyglot the great promise
of micro services especially
older material coming out of early
adopting companies the great promise is
if you build a micro service based
architecture and you keep your
interfaces lean and simple and
cross-platform that's why HTTP and and
Jason are so successful the idea is you
can have as many text axes you want but
it turns out that you're not actually
gonna need it so this is kind of a best
faith effort like a half a day or so of
googling on my part to try and figure
out how many independent back in tech
stacks each of these companies has I
don't know how accurate it is because
it's not the sort of thing you can just
go ahead and ask but I want to point out
that with one outlier which is Facebook
each and every one of these fairly
substantial very successful companies
has 3/4 thick stacks Google with their
again googling I don't know if that's
true 30,000 or so software engineers
have six tech stacks
this gives us a nice rule of thumb if
you have more than one or two texts ax
per five thousand engineers you're doing
it wrong you just don't need it more
importantly though you're not actually
gonna want it and I'm gonna I'm gonna
rail against this because as in a highly
individualistic person I hate technology
technology decisions being dictated to
me by the organization I like to pill
pick the right tool for the job but it
turns out that there are a lot of there
is a lot of overhead inherent in having
multiple text ax and very few
organizations actually do that and even
when they do they usually end up a few
years later converging on a very small
set of text stacks because if you have a
small set of text ax you can actually
mobilize people between teams
it makes hiring easier it makes helping
out a a fellow team member from a
different team possible because if
you're building in Ruby and the team
next-door is working and go you're not
actually going to be able to help out
and you're not the you're not going to
be able to move between teams very
rapidly because there's a huge learning
curve involved so it turns out that for
the most part you're not even gonna
to have that that sort of freedom that
comes with microcircuits but it sure
feels nice
I really wish this was more relevant to
real life software engineering but in
effect hardly anyone does that I'm sure
some do I'm sure some are very happy
with it
but as a rule of thumb you're not gonna
need more than two or three tech stacks
in your back-end systems there so just
to just to repeat for everyone
the upshot of this is if you pick
quote-unquote a wrong tech stack having
a microservice architecture does allow
you to replace that moving forward and
that's that's kind of true hopefully you
did not select the text ACK you
regretted but that does happen another
thing we've managed to learn as an
industry is that Conway knew what he was
talking about so here's a traditional
traditional quote from Conway
fundamentally though the intuition
around Conway's law is whatever you end
up doing the organizational structure
and the structure of your your system
architecture will end up looking the
same and you'll note that I didn't say
one derives from the other they both can
try to move independently but over time
they will converge so that tells us that
you need to structure your teams in a
way that reflects the architecture that
you want and vice versa
because they're gonna end up converging
on the same structure and that tells us
there are a few common danger signs that
I think as an industry we've learned to
recognize and deal with two common
danger sign danger signs for shall we
say violating quote/unquote Conway's law
are a data store that's shared between
multiple multiple services
I hope it's pretty clear why that's a
terrible idea but something that does
still happen but I feel we've learned to
recognize and deal with more and more is
a single system or a single domain of
responsibility that's shared between
multiple teams and that is also a
terrible idea because it
means that there's a diffusion of
responsibility and increased
synchronization in order to move forward
in that particular domain so if you're
violating the single responsibility
principle in your architecture you or in
your organization you really have two
options you can reorganize your services
to match the sort of organizational
structure that you want or vice versa
because they're going to end up looking
the same and if the way they end up
looking is not conducive to your doing
business and increase the
synchronization cost it diffuses
responsibilities you're gonna have a
very painful problem on your hands
the I think last thing we've learned is
that operations matter this is the
impetus behind the whole DevOps movement
such as such as it is
in order to attain independent releases
in order to allow developers to move as
fast as possible whether independent
pieces of your system you need to ship
fast and you need to disallow any
bottlenecks that stand between a
developer with a commit and that commit
running in production that is why we've
been moving progressively from a global
release and it doesn't matter if it's
every three months every six months or
every day between a global release of
the whole set of things that comprise
your system to many many small rapid
iterations on independent pieces of your
system that are deployed independently
we moved from a centralized op structure
where the ops team typically is in
charge of deploying your your app to
distributed ownership now we have
operations teams providing
infrastructure for engineers to actually
deploy their systems independently
without that throwing over the fence
that was so common say a decade ago we
moved from manual deployment to full
automation because manual deployment is
a major bottleneck and a major cause of
errors we moved from static topologies
to ephemeral auto scaled systems right
we're running in the cloud running an
Amazon we do auto scaling groups we
don't we treat our
servers as what is that this cattle not
as pets I think that's the expression
right we have learned those lessons
DevOps used to be this new thing that's
hard to explain to people nowadays it's
almost a given if you have an ops team
that deals with deployments as opposed
to infrastructure you're gonna get
laughed at and for very good reasons
unless of course you're doing something
extremely as a Tareq
so DevOps is a good thing we've learned
that we've also learned that automation
is key we're automating everything we're
automating infrastructure infrastructure
is code with terraform and such we're
automating deployment we have big
deployment orchestration systems that we
did not have ten years ago right we have
the Spinnaker's of the world whereas ten
years ago you would have simply whatever
copied off an RPM somewhere and
installed its manual in the system
we are automating monitoring we're
automating remediation and and
provisioning and everything we possibly
can we're automating so that we can move
faster and the reason we care about
automating all these things is we've
learned that we want to move faster into
small we want to have many independent
teams doing their work as fast as
possible with as few dependencies and
other teams and other people as possible
automation is an empowerment tool it
means your default pers can move faster
whereas ten years ago they not only
would not be able to move faster we
didn't even know how to build our
organizations in a way that allows them
to move that fast
so these are all things I think we have
as an industry learn these are all good
lessons and I feel that these are mostly
solve problems the tools might not be
there but the methodology and the
perception is let's talk about sadder
things things we have not yet learned
one thing we have failed as an industry
I feel to learn are laws of physics we
are in this room mostly software
engineers I imagine not all of us but
for the most part we are engineers if we
were asked to design an airplane we
wouldn't imagine
trying to design an airplane without a
very very well rooted understanding of
at least Newtonian physics right that's
Newton in case anyone was wondering all
right we wouldn't even imagine it and if
we tried our plane would crash seconds
after takeoff that's assuming it managed
to take off to begin with and it
probably wouldn't so why are we as an
industry so comfortable ignoring these
two people Leslie Lamport on the left
and Eric Brewer on the right these are
two of the people that define the laws
of physics for distributed systems as we
know them Lamport did some of the most
some of the earliest and most important
research on distributed systems Brewer
codified the cat theorem right these
things define the rules of the reality
that we live in and yet we're perfectly
comfortable designing these systems
well not fully understanding or not
fully intuiting the laws of physics that
those two guys on the Left gave us right
and we keep doing that and we keep
telling ourselves that it's not a big
deal because we're not really you know
we're not building distributed systems
and just building this client-server
thing or line of business app but we're
all building distributed systems as soon
as you have your server and a mace equal
somewhere or you have your iphone firing
off an HTTP request at a web server in
the cloud somewhere once you have two or
more moving parts that comprise your
system as we all do you're building a
distributed system and in a distributed
system concurrency is the key if you
don't have a reasonable intuition around
availability and consistency you're
gonna end up building production systems
that have inconsistent data between data
stores between data centers they will
not scale they will lose data repeatedly
right all of these things happen in a
lot of the production systems we build
simply because for whatever reason is an
industry we're still comfortable
building systems that flat-out violate
the laws of physics and that is very
very sad and more importantly there's
really
no reason for that next thing I feel we
have felt learned that because
distributed systems are by nature large
and disaggregate systems many many
moving parts that move around
independently we fail to realize that we
need to invest in observability and I
think that over the last couple years
this has finally been getting sort of
the line light that it deserves but we
are still very much deficient in the
tools and the practices that are
required to make sense and reason about
the sort of assist large-scale micro
service based systems that we've that
were building and that we've built now
tools are becoming better five years ago
I would not be able to write this slide
five years ago we didn't have these
tools nowadays you actually have a lot
of open-source aftermarket tools that
you can employ to gain observability in
your systems you have tracing tools you
have tools for the aggregation and
visualization and graphing of metrics
you have centralized log aggregators you
have the elk stack and you have all
these aftermarket products like New
Relic etc that let you gain
observability into your system in a
sensible way unfortunately that's not
enough having tools is a very very good
thing because we didn't have those a few
years back but we're still as an
industry very deficient in the
methodology around how to employ these
tools to actually gain insight into the
systems that we build in order to make
sense of distributed system that's big
that has a lot of moving parts that are
that are doing stuff independently we
need to have a much more a much stronger
approach and much stronger reasoning in
order to answer questions such as what
should I even log right if you if you
take almost any production system and
you look at the sort of logging
statements that are included in the code
base they are I would say somewhere
between a valiant attempt and utterly
useless like we're not logging things
that anyone including ourselves actually
care about we log because we've
told that we need to log not because
we're planning on these logs to be
useful to us in the future in order to
debug the system and that's a problem we
also have don't have a rigorous
methodology about what it is we should
count
what sort of metrics do we care about
what effects our system what are the
KPIs for any particular production
system that you need to monitor so that
you know when the system is in trouble
or that it's outgrowing its scaling
envelope for its existing architecture
or any of these things these are hard
questions there are no easy answers but
I feel that for the most part most of us
have been ignoring those questions for
years and that is that is a problem
fortunately it also seems that this that
there's sort of a movement in the other
direction where a lot of us have
realized that it's very very hard to
gain any sense out of what's going on in
our systems and that is why we're
starting to invest in tools
what should we monitor and most
importantly the bottom line is once we
have all that data we are still severely
deficient in the phonology about how to
make sense of it right we have all these
metrics all these logs all these
different things coming out of our
system we don't really have a industry a
rigorous methodology that tells us what
to do about it what kind of questions we
need to ask how to aggregate metrics I'm
sorry to have to say this but a lot of a
lot of engineers and a lot of companies
are still perfectly comfortable doing
stuff like looking at average response
times which is the single most useless
metric on earth and if you don't know
why that's a single useless metric then
you will have proved my point right as
an industry we have still not properly
properly learned to deal with
distributed systems from an
observability standpoint and with all
those sort of unfortunate lacks of
learning I think there are still some
things we can do today to start
improving the state of affairs in our
various
and although the title is explosive none
of the things I'm gonna be talking about
for the remaining four and a half
minutes of this talk should come as any
surprise to you but before we talk about
my opinion on what it is we should be
doing let's do a quick recap on what it
is we're trying to accomplish here
we aim to minimize synchronization and
maximize team independence that is what
we want what's hard for us is to build
systems that are safe that deal
correctly with data that do not violate
the laws of physics that don't lose data
or get incorrect data in through through
faulty designs we want scalability
scalability is still not an easy thing
to deal with for a lot of these systems
and we want observability these are the
three things we want and it turns out
that we already have some tools that let
us design our systems in a way where the
two goals are met and the three things
we're struggling with are somewhat
mitigated and a lot of those techniques
circle round events it turns out events
are your friends and events make
everything that much simpler if you
designed your system with events in mind
and I will of course delve into what
that actually could actually mean then
you end up with systems that are more
resilient more observable less wrong and
are actually simpler that are easier to
reason about easier to think about
easier to build and easier to deal with
an events come into play in three major
ways in sort of systems we end up
building one way we can use events is in
modeling interactions between our
various services we all know and love
our PC and some use cases make perfect
sense for our PC and very little sense
for other things but it turns out that a
lot of the flows that are built into
your systems you can actually model as
services emitting and consuming events
again this should not be news right
we've we've had talks about you know
event based systems in this conference
and in every other conference over the
last 10 years now the advantage of
modeling modeling the interactions
between your services as events being
emitted and consumed is that an enforcer
strong context boundaries if you only
emit events and only consume events that
is the surface area of your service by
definition you have to seriously
consider what the what the context
boundaries for your service are right
otherwise you just can't reason about
what sort of events you need to emit and
what sort of events you need to consume
it also lets you like assuming you have
a scalable event bus or message broker
or whatever it is you use it also allows
you to scale your services independently
if service a publishes events and those
events are useful to services B and C
but in completely separate ways more
importantly services B and C might have
completely different scaling
characteristics and requirements you can
do that you can build those services
independently consume the same events
and scale those services in very very
different ways and because you're
omitting events and consuming events it
makes it that much easier to actually
observe what's going on in the system
because you can consume those events as
part of your observability story and
finally it also tends a synchronous
flows also tend to be tend to increase
system reliability especially for
complex flows the other way in which you
can use events that I highly recommend
you look into is essentially event
sourcing instead of storing your
business entities as mutable rows in a
database you can store them as a
successive sequence of events that
change the state of your your particular
business entity canonical example is of
course a bank account your bank account
is not your my English sucks today I
forgot the word it's not the number you
see when you look at your ATM and ask
how much money do I have left in my bank
account it's not your balance right your
bank account is the succession of events
succession of deposits and withdrawals
out of your bank account and putting all
those together give
the balance and there are a lot of
benefits to storing your data in that
way observability is built in as is
auditing right if you only save what
happened as opposed to do results of
that thing happening then you have
observability built into your system and
at let's see scale read and write use
cases independently which is the impetus
for the CQRS pattern on which there was
a talk yesterday at this very conference
the apparent downside of this is that it
precludes full consistency right if you
if you store events then ostensibly you
can't get full consistency out of it you
can only get eventual consistency out of
your systems I submit that that is a
good thing because unlike the narrow
field of software engineering virtually
nothing in life is fully consistent no
business that has more than say one
branch is fully consistent no bank no
bank account no banking system is fully
consistent they all have to deal with
the laws of physics and the reality that
in order to provide service you have to
give up consistency in order to get
availability right the world we live in
is essentially eventually consistent so
giving up on this facade the full
consistency that you're used to from
your traditional database systems and
your traditional architectures only ends
up with systems that are actually easier
to reason about and work more reliably
and faster at that the last use case for
events is modeling workflows this is
what's called the saga pattern and is a
very big topic that's totally outside
the scope suffice to say that for the
most part sagas give you what you need
or what you use to want out of database
transactions at a fraction of the cost
and they're not super complex to build
again large topic we have no time to go
into it but I would highly recommend
digging into the saga pattern it is a
very very useful tool to have in your
toolbox
the bottom line is for my money you
should sweat the principles not the
implementation details for the last ten
years we've been mostly focusing on what
it entails to build a microcircuits
based system we've been talking about
RPC subsystems and monitoring in circuit
breakers and all of these things and all
of these things over the last few years
have been commoditized if you're
building a micro service framework for
your organization you're probably
wasting your time and wasting your
company's money a lot of these tools can
be can now be taken off the shelf and
integrated into your micro service
substrate and they will do a much better
job than you would have done five years
ago so instead of spending the time
learning about how to implement circuit
breakers and how to do HTTP 200 reliably
and efficiently and whether you should
see relize stuff as Jason or protobuf or
thrift just pick any one of those tools
and spend your time investing in studies
spend your time learning the laws of
physics namely the cap theorem and
various trade-offs that are involved
with it spend your time learning how to
model your domains how to do event
storming which is nice technique for for
starting to draw those boundaries around
your different contexts learn about
events or seeing in CQRS learn about
sagas if you spend your time doing these
things you'll be much better off you'll
end up building systems that are more
performant more reliable you will enable
your organization to grow faster you
will be able to build additional product
lines based on your pre-existing
products faster and more reliably you'll
be better off all around I will leave
you with these two lengths one of them
is totally a shameless plug by the way
but first there is this talk by Deven
CTO of gilt Michael price ik which is
called design micro service
architectures the right way he's dishing
out a lot of wisdom there and then if
you're interested in events or saying
there's my own talk called an abridged
guide to event sourcing which will
hopefully be useful to you in getting
started and I can flat-out guarantee if
any of these things sounds hard or
sounds scary to you they actually are
not as soon as you start looking into
how to actually build these systems you
will find that they are a lot simpler
not only than you think then that you're
used to from traditional architectures
and with that we are out of time
thank you very very much
[Applause]